the thing about this movie is it gave a
lot of people hope for what could be
possible in movies for women for years
to come that 20 years have gone by have
we gotten to a better place there was so
much press about it and a lot of it was
well this proves a million different
things that that a movie starring two
women can be a big success that people
love women buddy movies and now we're
gonna see a whole raft of movies as a
result of this it was really good cuz I
remember you telling me a few years
later and you said you had a friend who
pitched a movie to a studio and it had
nothing to do with this movie except
that it had two women in it and she said
that they had passed on it because they
said we've had them and Louise like I
know there can only be one movie with
two women in it but my very next movie
league of their own was the same
phenomenon where it was a big hit and
everyone said well now this proves one
so we're all women's sports movies are
can be very successful people it's
inexplicable obviously that the numbers
of women participating in every single
level level from writing to directing to
any any behind the scenes or in front of
the camera or the numbers are
embarrassingly low brights mates will go
out and make more money than knocked up
and then you still have the same you're
pushing the same rock uphill there's
been plenty of female studio heads that
I haven't seen like you know singling
out women going okay one of our mandates
is that we're gonna make pictures
directed to a female audience you know
maybe some of these females to be exact
I don't know what this is true or not
wouldn't have those positions if they
did because above them and the people
controlling the media and big
conglomerate
- only a few are just I don't know
there's like 90% control and
decision-making power by men
you know and so maybe that has something
to do with it I have a theory about why
it keeps happening like this the whole
system of operation in Hollywood is
based on the belief that women will
watch men but men won't watch women and
then that's why we never get any
momentum because every movie is seen as
a one-off yeah but but but in general
and I don't we don't trust that that
really works it worked for that movie
but it's not gonna work again and so
when it comes right down to it they just
keep catering to the male audience
because young male I'm gonna go anyway
it's the young male audience and I think
that's where the difference is because I
think older men are in control of their
faculties enough to be able to sit
through a movie with a female lead and
not take it as an insult you know and
maybe there aren't enough directors like
Ridley Scott who can see honesty for
what it is because I really think that
did make an enormous difference here
that he was willing to go for it
he's always put strong women his movies
from Sigourney Weaver to Daryl Hannah
well you should see his wife she she
will kick your ass